i would i would you know even if i got
like paid on top of doing the wedding
because i'm assuming the
the like kind of the reason why people
apply for that show is you get a free
wedding right yeah yeah
but like man organizing a wedding seems
like one of
the easiest things to get wrong in
and i was like god damn just the like
because you know like
all right you have friends right but
like not every friend you want to come
to your wedding right
so that must be so [ __ ] awkward
deciding like
you're you're a good enough friend but
like i don't know if
you're like good enough for the wedding
i can barely organize a boy's night out
let alone
also like you have like how many friends
do you have right and like where do you
draw the line who's close enough how do
you decide
is it like a mutual thing you're like no
i don't like ted like winning politics
is like definitely
i think it's so difficult my my cousin
went through it as well and it's just
it's ah there's there's a lot that goes
into a wedding that
i like
it's like trying to plan a wedding
yourself is hard enough trying to plan a
wedding
internet like when you're not in the
country yeah and also during like covert
here
[Music]
this this is this is like not even like
hard mode this is like dark souls no
no like there's so many things that
can like that can [ __ ] up as well i love
that nowadays whenever anything is like
extremely hard the first thing you think
is dark souls nothing's harder than that
yeah i mean it's stressful but it's it's
rewarding
yeah it must be i think i mean is it
going on i mean it's rewarding
he's watching yes yes it's rewarding
until like it will be rewarding once it
actually finishes right yeah and
everything goes smooth i mean i mean
like the planning parts
some of it's better than the others like
i remember like my favorite moment so
far has been
actually going to the venue and just
being like yeah this is the place this
is the place that's an amazing feeling
everything up to that like searching
through about 50 catalogues of possible
places and driving to about 10 different
places
places and being like uh do i want to
settle on this
i don't know can i see myself getting
married in a barn or a cave
or whatever in japan it's like crazy how
like [ __ ] seriously they take this
oh yeah oh it's it's eve it's like in
asia
they're like we think there's like
wedding politics in western weddings no
in asia it's a [ __ ] statement
yeah right and i hate that i i
absolutely hate that because there's so
many unspoken rules
the amount that they must spend on
weddings here oh it's not yeah
it's insane if you go to like any like
fancy hotel
in japan like you just cause you know if
you go there for like a lunch or
something you'll see that like the
wedding planning rooms are like
full with people yeah yeah and like
those prices don't seem cheap
they seem real expensive like 50k on a
wedding i'm like
what yeah i went i went to one of my
friend's weddings from university and he
did it in japan in tokyo
and the inside of this venue looked like
a [ __ ] mini disneyland
like it was there was like a castle and
like a [ __ ] fountain and this like
massive
completely white charge i'm like how
much money do you just yeah how about
like what amount of money is too much to
spend on a wedding i get that it's a
special day but there has to be a limit
well like a special day is like
ridiculous
there was like 300 people at this
wedding yeah because like nobody knows
300 people
i'm sorry i don't even know if i have to
even have that many friends on facebook
let alone
i don't know what it is do you like
families asking like hey can my like
family friend of a friend come
do you get like that because i feel like
i'd be like no i don't [ __ ] know them
in japan it's like the wedding politics
extends to like
you have to work right now yeah yeah
cause because it's all about the face
right so
like in in thailand you have to invite
your family your family friends your
work colleagues like basically everyone
i mean close colleagues yeah
you know yeah they've got that actual
message inviting my boss
yeah and another thing about thai
weddings
shut up lately which is why like me and
tiny decided to have our wedding in the
uk so we didn't have to worry about you
know that that side of
that [ __ ] but like it it's a
customary entire wedding's as well that
the groom has to give money have to have
to give like a certain amount of money
to the bride's like family for his like
father to accept or something
that's like [ __ ] russian like mother
right he's like i give you two goats
this feels like this feels like an extra
step to like auction you know
yeah i mean it's something that i don't
agree with and i've seen like some of my
family members do it i'm just like
yeah i don't know i don't care i kind of
don't agree with this is that where it
comes from like where does that come
from that like honestly i have no idea
does it come from something more
sinister like where you've been it must
be
they must i mean i'm not i'm not sure
how the custom started because you know
like it's it's something that i've
attended thai weddings and i've seen
happen
um i've i've never kind of asked where
where where this where this came from i
just kind of was just like
yeah i don't think i want to do that did
you buy mom
yeah i mean like
[Music]
the same customary where it's like the
bride's dad is expected to play for his
wedding
and i'm just like no that shouldn't be
the case either yeah right
like it's it's it's to me a wedding
there's
there's so many customaries to weddings
where that revolve around money that i
just don't understand
i guess because like maybe i mean that
was common that's pretty common in the
west still right that the
uh the other person the bridegroom the
bride's parents will pay
but i mean it's understandable when
marriage used to be
way younger like 21. yeah yeah yeah yeah
i get it then cause you don't have any
money
but now people are getting married at
what like 20 70 30 30
so it's like you know i mean you
probably should have your own money by
then you know like yeah
we should be planning a wedding if
you're unemployed at 30.
maybe yeah you're just dissing yourself
yeah i mean
just saying yeah i'm sorry for that guy
who just like
you know had like five children and all
of them ended up being
daughters and he's like [ __ ]
come on come on son son son oh my god
it's like the uh like aging population
like pyramid thing right
it won't bite you now i'll bite you
later
yeah because isn't that like i remember
i saw like this i don't remember it was
a vice documentary or some kind of
documentary on youtube where like
i forgot which country it was somewhere
in the middle east where like they still
have the tradition
of like wife napping where it's like
they they did i forgot which country it
was but i remember i saw this
documentary and there's this tradition
quote unquote tradition where guys
if they find a girl that they find
attractive and they see as
wife material some of them will actually
like dead-ass kidnap them
like in broad daylight take them back to
their parents place and
the girl is then forced to get married
to this guy what is this like [ __ ]
real-life pokemon sounds like runescape
this sounds like runescape
and like and like traditionally the girl
can't decline it
really yeah so like that she has to get
married in and and there's all these and
this documentary i saw is like it's so
[ __ ] disturbing because there's these
girls who are literally just
breaking down while they get the veil
put on top of them and [ __ ] and it's
just
it's [ __ ] oh i i i wish i could
remember the
the name of the documentary the trash
taste podcast i was like there was this
thing i don't remember that
this thing i saw on the internet i
vaguely remember that but there's one
detail i remember that i want to talk
about now and just share to the world
isn't that [ __ ] up i remember a
perfect example of that i think was the
uh
there was one episode we were talking
about like uh how
how very rarely like anime uses english
like songs and their openings and
endings
and we're bringing up all these titles
and we're like oh i'm sure there's other
ones we don't know
all the titles are like jojo
hello you know that one show you're all
obsessed about
i just forget everything all the time i
feel like when you put on the spot
oh yeah especially when you put on the
spot like you're recording and you're
recording it's just
never take our word on anything that's
that's just the golden rule
we are not liable for anything that we
yeah